[Música]
el comité de la cámara de representantes
Que investigó los hechos relacionados
con el intento de toma del Capitolio en
Estados Unidos recomendó en su informe
final acusar al expresidente Donald
Trump por obstrucción e insurrección
un Jurado del estado de California
encontró culpable al ex productor de
Hollywood Harvey weinstein por cargos de
violación y agresión sexual Ahora sólo
resta que la justicia dictamine Qué tipo
de Pena impone tras haberlo encontrado
culpable
y buena parte del servicio de
Electricidad y agua ya fue restablecido
en kiev la capital ucraniana tras
intensos ataques con drones por parte de
las fuerzas armadas rusas que afectaron
seriamente la infraestructura hidráulica
y eléctrica de la ciudad
muy buenas noches América Latina
bienvenidos Estas son las noticias de
France 24 soy Santiago López González
vamos a comenzar en la ciudad de
Washington en Estados Unidos en donde el
comité de la cámara de representantes
Que investigó los hechos ocurridos
durante el intento de la toma el
Capitolio el 6 de enero del 2021 sugirió
que el expresidente Donald Trump sea
acusado por obstrucción e insurrección
un pedido a la justicia el comité
legislativo que Investiga el asalto del
6 de enero del 2021 al Capitolio
recomienda el departamento de Justicia
estadounidense imputar el expresidente
Donald Trump por obstrucción de la
justicia incitación al terrorismo
conspiración en contra del gobierno
federal y declaraciones falsas a la
justicia
La fe es la base de la Democracia
estadounidense si se rompe la fe se
rompe nuestra democracia y Donald Trump
la rompió perdió las elecciones de 2020
y lo sabía buscaba anular los resultados
con la intervención de varias partes
para bloquear la transferencia de poder
tras un año y medio de investigaciones
la comisión considera que Trump no actúa
en solitario además de encontrar que
pasó la tarde bien del ataque por
televisión el 6 de enero de 2021 unas
10.000 personas se manifestaron en
frente del Capitolio y cerca de 800
irrumpieron en el edificio mientras se
ratificaba la victoria del demócrata en
las elecciones presidenciales hubo cinco
muertos y unos 140 heridos
fue la primera vez que un presidente
estadounidense rechazó su deber
constitucional de transferir el poder
pacíficamente al siguiente Durante los
últimos 18 meses el comité selecto ha
reconocido nuestra obligación de hacer
todo lo posible para garantizar que esto
nunca suceda otra
esta fue la última audiencia del 2022 en
la cual el comité quiso difundir sus
conclusiones antes de la nueva
legislatura el 3 de enero la mayoría
republicana que habrá a partir de ese
día podría disolver este órgano y el
enjuiciamiento sería detenido y después
de varias semanas de audiencias y nueve
días de deliberaciones un Jurado del
estado de California en Estados Unidos
encontró culpable al ex productor de
Hollywood Harvey weinstein por cargos de
violación y agresión sexual en este caso
weinstein también enfrentaba dos cargos
de violación y otros cinco por agresión
sexual en hechos ocurridos entre los
años 2005 y 2013 en la ciudad de Los
Ángeles en California el ex Magnate que
esperaba sentencia tras las rejas ya fue
sentenciado a 23 años de prisión por
otro caso similar pero en el estado de
Nueva York ahora ahora solo resta que la
justicia californiana dicte algún tipo
de Sentencia sobre el caso
nos vamos ahora hasta Perú el gobierno
de Dina boluarte afirmó que las
protestas en diferentes zonas del país
han comenzado a desescalar después de
que al menos 23 personas perdieron la
vida entre tanto la mandataria peruana
cambió de Primer Ministro mientras que
la cancillería protestó por las que
consideran son injerencias de gobiernos
de izquierda de América Latina más
detalles en el siguiente informe
los gobiernos de izquierda de
latinoamérica mantienen la presión sobre
Perú este lunes el presidente de México
Andrés Manuel López Obrador volvió a
insistir en su oferta de asilo para el
presidente derrocado Pedro Castillo
actualmente en prisión preventiva
mientras la cancillería peruana envió
una carta a su contraparte colombiana el
presidente Gustavo Petro ha estado
cuestionando en sus redes el
encarcelamiento de Castillo las
afirmaciones del presidente Pedro
constituyen una injerencia inaceptable
en los asuntos internos del Perú
especialmente grave en el contexto de
actos de violencia que han ocasionado
lamentables pérdidas de Vidas humanas
una semana después de nombrar gabinete
la nueva presidente Dina boluarte dijo
que iba a reformarlo cambiando el Primer
Ministro Pedro Angulo y asegura que las
protestas están cediendo pero las
imágenes todavía lo desmienten en la
frontera entre Bolivia y Perú hay más de
mil camiones varados estamos esperando
desde el día martes en la noche
cosa que no nos dan paso ya mirar son
cuántos días y ya se nos acaba la
economía los manifestantes han cerrado
el puente internacional que conecta
ambos países
emprendiendo la lucha apoyando a
nuestros hermanos de Lima por tantas
muertes que hubo por el problema que
tenemos por el mismo hecho por haberle
bajaba Castillo la institución de Pedro
Castillo el 7 de diciembre ha desatado
la ira por todo el país en unas
protestas que ya dejan más de 20 muertos
Y nuevamente la capital de Ucrania fue
escenario de bombardeos y de ataques con
cerca de 35 drones por parte de las
tropas rusas los ataques dejaron tres
personas heridas y daños considerables
en la infraestructura eléctrica e
hidráulica de la ciudad
el lunes este pueblo a 40 kilómetros de
quieva amaneció en medio de la
desolación en plena noche la casa de
esta pareja de ancianos fue alcanzada
por un dron su garaje prendió en llamas
el hombre resultó herido
seguía vibrando muy fuerte Entonces se
produjo una explosión muy fuerte y nos
preguntamos Cómo acabaría todo esto para
nosotros
durante toda la noche las sirenas
sonaron en la región de kiev objetivo de
otro asalto aéreo ruso el tercero en
solo seis días una vez más la
infraestructura energética del país fue
blanco como la empresa donde trabaja
esta mujer que escuchó las expresiones
de camino al trabajo
[Música]
Estoy muy ansiosa ansiosa porque nunca
sabes cuándo se acercará a un misil Pero
en cuanto salta la alerta antiaérea
abandonamos inmediatamente la oficina
los ataques provocaron nuevos cortes de
agua y electricidad en kiev y 10
regiones del país mientras millones de
ucranianos siguen sumidos en la
oscuridad y el frío desde el pasado
viernes según el presidente Ucrania no
los drones responsables de los asaltos
son de fabricación iraní
anoche 34 drones iraníes sahead
volvieron a atacar Ucrania llegó su
cantidad y su nombre con mucha precisión
son del nuevo lote que Rusia recibió de
Irán
tras este ataque volvió a pedirle a
occidente que proporcione más armas a
Ucrania ya que sus efectivos temen un
posible ataque ruso contra principios de
y Mientras tanto en el Líbano la falta
de alumbrado público ha permitido un
aumento de la delincuencia en las calles
de beirut la capital del país Esto llevó
a que un centenar de personas crearan
una vigilancia vecinal para protegerse
ante las limitaciones de las fuerzas de
seguridad
no son más de las 10 de la tarde pero la
sensación es de media noche recibe una
llamada y organiza el resto del grupo
para salir a patrullar por las rafia la
falta de alumbrado público en las calles
ha hecho aumentar la delincuencia en
este barrio cristiano de virus Has visto
cómo estás completamente oscuras es un
derecho básico que nuestros vecinos
nuestros hijos se sientan seguros cuando
salgan o regresen a sus casas por eso
estamos aquí un total de 120 voluntarios
entrenados por una compañía de seguridad
participan en esta iniciativa de
vigilancia vecinal para proteger al
barrio mariama ha tenido que adelantar
la hora de cierre de la tienda porque no
se siente segura con la calle oscuras
antes cerraba a las pero ahora no hay
luz en la calle y no vienen clientes
está desierta me da miedo no hay
seguridad
en un país como Líbano marcado
profundamente por el sectarismo el hecho
de que un grupo de vigilantes nocturnos
reclutado por un importante partido
cristiano haya decidido actuar por su
cuenta ha creado controversias para
Michelle sabaré que vivió la guerra
civil y apoyando cristiano esta
iniciativa de vigilancia vecinal es un
regreso al pasado
es un tiempo complicado estamos sin
presidente ni gobierno todo el mundo
está pidiendo que se desmantele la
milicia es peligroso tener ahora otro
grupo encargándose de la seguridad en su
zona
pero el diputado navideño
2020 rechaza que su iniciativa comparte
similitudes con las patrullas durante la
Guerra Civil de Vanessa
no estamos en una guerra civil todo lo
contrario no estamos para reemplazar a
las fuerzas de seguridad trabajamos en
completa coordinación con la policía y
las agencias de seguridad interna
y más allá de la polémica mientras el
barrio las oscuras estos vigilantes
nocturnos continuarán resguardando su
comunidad ante las limitaciones de las
fuerzas policiales para dar seguridad
punto final en las noticias de France 24
siga con nosotros
[Música]